20-18 was supposed to be the year that
dreams of self-driving cars became a
reality while car companies continue to
unveil new driverless concepts those
predictions of a truly autonomous
vehicle may be a lot further away than
we think Tim Stevens is editor-in-chief
of the automotive website Roadshow at
our partners scene at Tim good morning
good morning
the Tesla and Google both said this is
the year but it isn't well it might be
for Google way most self-driving
technology is expected to be available
in the Phoenix area this year so if you
happen to live there you might actually
be living in the future before the end
of the year but for those of us who live
elsewhere we still got a little out of
weight unfortunately and Tesla yeah
absolutely we still have a lot of weight
there too why is that ultimately the
technology is almost ready at this point
the sensors are there and a lot of the
supercomputing power that you need is
almost developed as well but they really
need more testing and they really need
the cost of this stuff to come down
those sensors are still very expensive
and the supercomputers that you need in
the trunk to process all the data those
are pretty pricey too to the point where
people really wouldn't be able to afford
this technology even if it were
available so for whammo you say the
technology is there what about the
regulation though the regulation is
definitely one of the bigger roadblocks
that's stopping this sort of development
right now Phoenix is kind of a hotbed
for testing because there's very little
legislation in that area which means
companies can kind of do whatever they
want to elsewhere in the US though it's
much more difficult and there are no
laws in place that will allow that kind
of testing to enable the companies to
really take the steps forward that they
need to do so well okay so if the tech
is there the regulatory infrastructure
is developing why do we keep seeing
these high-profile crashes of these
automotive self-driving cars there have
been very few crashes actually if you
look at the number of miles of these
cars are covering whammo in particular
the form of Google's self-driving car
project has covered millions and
millions of miles with very few
incidents in those crashes that they
have had have been actually the fault of
other drivers so actually these cars are
proving to be more safe than human
drivers but of course whenever there is
a crash we have so much more data about
those crashes that we can really examine
them in a lot of minutia we talked about
legislation Tim what about the insurance
industry being ready for this change
it's definitely a big concern for
insurance of course because these cars
are expected to be much more safer of
course but there's a lot of questions
about who is liable in a crash and
ultimately will you even need insurance
right now of course you certainly will
because laws and every state require
that kind of thing but
going forward we may see a different
sort of approach to buying cars or
actually you buy into a car access
program and insurance it's kind of baked
into that we're beginning to see things
like that already Volvo for example as a
program called care by volume Volvo
where you don't buy a car you pay a
given amount per month and you get a car
plus insurance and everything else that
you need it's interesting I interviewed
the CEO of uber a couple of months ago
and they were introducing their flight
they're driving taxis and so I'm curious
as to while these companies are
developing the technology the demand is
not quite there yet
so what do they see that consumers don't
see yeah in fact there's there's not
only demand there's actually fear we see
study after study that shows that
Americans are afraid of this technology
that they don't want cars to drive
themselves but the belief is that
they'll be so practical so convenient
and so safe that ultimately people will
begin to change their minds and for a
company like uber they spend most of
their money on the salaries of drivers
so they can actually take that person
out of the car they don't only get a lot
cheaper but they get rid of a lot of the
risks that they've had with background
checks and things like that some of the
bigger problems that they face suddenly
all go away well I mean it's hugely
disruptive for the labor industry to
write news those are all jobs yeah place
them with robots self-driving cars that
changes how people are making a dollar
absolutely I'm Stephen thanks for that
thank you